to movie stars gearing up for
hollywood's big night the oscars oh i
like that nichelle oscar's got a little
put a little jazz on it because it's
coming up just 19 days away and all the
nominees got together to break bread and
have a few laughs at the star-studded
oscars luncheon
will smith started the party before he
even got inside sharing a hug with
steven spielberg
posing with king richard co-star ingenue
ellis and greeting longtime pal denzel
washington
denzel just wanted to know bradley
cooper's age
he's actually 47 denzel's 67 but
noticeably absent from the annual event
nominee nicole kidman who e.t has
learned is at home in nashville under
doctor's orders recovering from a torn
hamstring but her being the ricardo's
co-star javier bardem was there with
wife penelope cruz they are only the
sixth married couple in oscar history to
be nominated for acting in the same year
though their two kids luna and leo are
not impressed they couldn't care less
it's like what the what no don't worry
the oscar what my daughter had an
important question which was
is there gonna be cake for this
celebration
that's the only thing that they wanted
to know it'll be the couple's second
oscar each if they win when the 94th
academy awards airs live march 27th on
abc marley matlin's historic oscar win
was 35 years ago this year she's hoping
coda star troy cotzer takes home some
hardware what do you remember about that
moment that win for children of a lesser
god i remember being shocked
in all honesty i got nominated while i
was at betty ford
in rehab but listen i was helping myself
and i'm still sober 35 years later along
with the anniversary of my win i heard
that you want to honor your late mother
with your oscars dress i told these
lovely designers do what you do but my
mother's name has to be somewhere i
would have wanted her with me
so
i'm gonna make sure that her name
will be seen it may make the dress not
be as pretty as they want it to be
[Music]
you